what a shot what a dangerous player what
a dangerous play a little bit of luck but
lot a skill to go along with it and that is a
beauty to remember L gets it back to Ben kly
returned and L has the goal what a play by Van
Tilly well you can see vanan Tilly he's sharp
with that puck good speed to the neutral zone here
Patrick l that's a heck of a play in traffic and
then what a beautiful pass wow Ling with that
play in traffic B Tilly spin around backhand
pass and sometimes it's just working he's on the
board got to being a healthy scratch not smiling
but I'm sure he's smiling big inside though oh
you know it here comes COV back over the boards
trying to chip that around give go COV to the
net across scores starts with a terrific cross
ice pass from Victor Hedman full width of the
ice to CRA who's streaking down the right wing
side nice little play right at the blue line by
Hegel to keep the play alive and then you knew
the coocher off on his back end he knows exactly
where Braden pointed and nothing the goal tender
can do Ingram got across there and took away
all the low stuff so really good finish there
for Braden [Music] Point here's aari off the
turnover R shot scores no aari goes upstairs
he got a cookie for tie short side shelfie what
a shot in the Long Reach of aari and the presence
of mind oh I'm just going to drag this from the
goal line out and tried to go short side with a
little traffic in front he finds that spot over
the shoulder here's Robertson left wing circle
is shot he scores he found a window over the
shoulder of Marr that is a goal scorer's goal
takes it outside he's being hurted he's shallow
the only window is right past the ear and if the
[Music] goldendelight.com opportunity on the
refer he scores you got to have roal to pull
this off motion I were up here going oh no
why didn't you shoot it well that's cuz he's
a better hockey player than you and me the little
fake right here Vadar he takes the Hook Line and
Sinker he slides to the post and you have to
be long 63 in a great hands to pull that off
and that is a thing of beauty neighbors gets
the loose Puck he's in the CLA shoots he scores
holy jump and what a goal he's got that goal
scorer's ability along with that ten and boy
did we see it on display loose do a good job
of moving the puck up out of the Zone just a
chip there by pav B and Jake neighbors turns on
the afterburners and then here's the best part
under control forehand backhand smooth as silk
puts that one in the back of the net pulls up
waiting for some help now into the Dallas Z trelo
fell down eel has the puck trying to move it lost
it gets it back iel scores Jack eel stayed with it
and wins it in overtime wow I give a little side
appreciation note to Alex petrangelo for holding
the line he ended up in the splits almost but eel
well he initially loses the puck which leads to a
fantastic goal at the end little bit of luck but
a lot of skill to go along with it this man to
the ice and out of the Zone it goes yes pulled
ahead by elers one-on-one Nikolai eers chips a
throw gets around and he shoots and scores this
doesn't happen without the brilliant little GI at
the defensive Blue Line get that little one touch
from Peretti into the Wheelhouse for eers good
pick up little inside out as he dances around the
defender speed is his weapon and when you combine
it with those kind of silky Ms to the top Corner
what a dangerous player what a dangerous play
Json had the lead twice here's grin in alone
he scores what a goal by m KY grin his first is
a shark and it's a beauty comes up with speed
attacks the middle good move the inside protects
the P pushes the stick away takes it right to the
hole puts it in what a big lift for the [Music]
Sharks Michel took that pass away Sabers get it
back again here's Benson in front what a move
score Zach Benson with his first NHL goal and
that is a beauty to remember for all time this
is total confidence going to the front of the
net and he pulls his back between his legs he's
going to put it right up top underneath the bar
no way keer expecting this and look at how easy it
was just simple effective and clean and you said
Dan that is a beauty and look at the young man
smiling right there the blues get it back and a
feet ahead and Hayes he's got to Breakaway in the
CLA Hayes scores what a goal good middle defense
by S and then Kevin Hayes takes off up the ice
and then what a move here everybody thought he
was going to the back hand at 6' five with that
reach there's no way that Ingram's going to be
able to get back across the creas to make that
play anytime he scores a goal looking up to the
heavens Hing his late brother Jimmy MC David won
a battle from behind the N cut C home well you
talk about getting rewarded for hard work winning
battles fighting for position that's exactly what
the Oilers do in this instance PR Birds can't
handle Conor McDavid as he backhand out with
intention to the front of the net irman does a
nice job of presenting his stick and getting on
the inside oh the defenseman slaven at first he's
behind him and watch here as he cleverly gets to
the inside and tips that to The Far Side of the
goal Bruins charge ahead three on two into the
Zone Coyle dances in back and scores an impressive
individual effort from Charlie Coy little smooth
backhander right there a heel to toe saucer right
inside the piping in and that is a beautiful goal
oh the dad's loving that PO a coil there he's got
her going Ponto on it sneaks around the defender
Frank to the front of the net great pass he
scor what a great individual effort by Frank
Pono Travis with the Finish Frank patrono is just
all hustle he beats his man along the boards wins
a puck battle and boy with a beautiful little feed
to McTavish like wheeler score oh is that a beauty
wheeler to zad and that's just a fabulous
redirection of the pass by wheeler who has
a couple of assists in this game Savanah Jad to
Wheeler and then aan just keeps going nobody picks
him up when he sees the Flyers his offense comes
yes wow wasch in the Box here from good Dr trying
to pick his way in good Dr back for go lightning
do a good job of getting the puck in the zone and
they get all four black jerseys over on one side
nice little backhand feather pass and when you
leave Stam with that much time and room stammer
from his office right at the face off dot that is
absolutely brilliant Zary down the way back one
goes for the mat there's the pass to Zer with a
terrific pass to back back push it oh what a set
up here's this pass by Zer a beautiful saucer pass
as backin goes to the net and all of a sudden this
Calgary flame group has now got a two goal cushion
to Raymond top of the right Circle pulls it back
nice play across scores par he was in the shooting
position and boy did he release that quickly Lucas
Raymond with a really good move at the high slot
against two Minesota flares and then a quick pass
and if this shot doesn't get off the Stick of pan
the minute it gets there it's not put in the net
and he wins the base off back to Darnell nurse a
bullet down the middle breakway new Hopkins he
scores and this is an absolute laser by Darnell
nurse you can't put this more on the tape look at
that sauce pass little turn to pick it up on the
forehand he shoots this from distance as well
as doall is way out to cut down that angle but
he Zips it just up over top of the pad just under
the blocker up high takes it from marchenko with
a shot save all rebound scores keep an eye on 38
Boon Jenner everyone knows this shot's coming from
line a Jenner screen and then keeps that play
moving gets it over to marchenko impressive
play here by the captain and Marko's got a little
cap in on the back door you practice when you're
scratch over there right oh what a play there's
the first of the year for JG Paso the Islanders
were able to keep that puck going as they slid
it over to barzel and he slides it quickly to
Paso and he's got an empty net he has such great
vision doesn't he I mean he didn't have to look at
all I mean that is so good not many players have
that kind of this will lead to a breakway Conor
McDavid in on Thompson score you left the most
dangerous guy allone behind you that puck just
bounced right to him he picks it up in motion no
chance you're catching him in that situation the
quick fit he brings it over to the forehand all
the way over to the back hand and Tucks it around
the left pad of Thompson and Conor McDavid stays
red hot long shot blocked up front by broin he's
able to Spring Baldi left Baldi in he scored
Baldi the benefactor but that play was made by
Jonas brine are you kidding me the block shot the
wherewithal to settle it down to hit the streaking
Matt Baldi he toe picks this one look at that he's
got the leg spread wide up quick little snapshot
plenty of flex on that stick flick of the wrists
up over the glove of [Music] Bennington [Music]